You are listening to radio lab radio from W.
N y. S. T. E. N. N. P. R.
Do you want to get out? Is this a, is this us? Yeah, this is okay.
[inaudible]
this is Radiolab. I'm Jad Abumrad.
Since our program today deals with stumbling upon the past in unlikely places,
we thought we'd begin this part of the show. Well,
not at a place we'd normally visit,
so I feel like we're standing on the top of a mountain. But how high up are we?
Right here? I believe we're about 180 this, by the way,
it's chief Dennis Diggins.
I'm an assistant chief from the New York City Department of sanitation and when
he says 180 he means feet at 180 feet high. Wow.
So that's about 18 stories. Correct.
18 stories up into the Staten island sky. That's where we're standing,
where we're standing on a hill, basically like a big dirt hill.
And in a glance you'd never know that this hill was made from anything other
than dirt. What did this used to be?
Unless of course you dug about a few feet down.
This is the whole garbage underneath this. Up until March of 2001,
we were taking in all of New York city's garbage.
All the boroughs were coming here, all the boroughs were coming here.
So we were probably taking it on average, 11,000 tons a day.
Fresh kills used to be the biggest dump on the planet.
That's all in the past with a little engineering help.
It's gotta be a great park. Absolutely. This will be a park.
And just look at how much property have you told these mounts are getting
wrapped in plastic and covered with grass. There'll be a restaurant.
Can almost imagine that I've in a golf course,
I would love to be the first ones to tee you off for this.
But underneath it all the garbage will still be here.
50 years of trash waiting patiently
until someone comes to look for it. And someone always does.
I know years ago we, there was a, uh,
a garb at arc arc yet, how do I say it right?
Archeological garbage shove man, the came here and he did some core sampling,
meaning with a special tool.
This guy board a hole deep into the center of the mound.
Actually came up with a a hotdog landfill.
10 years previously. Kidding.
The hot dog that was 10 years old and it was still hot. Still hot though.
Recognizably a hotdog.
That's amazing and disgusting.
I still like hotdog so I'll eat it. Seriously.
Do you ever consider the history that's contained in this?
In this big chunk of garbage? Oh yeah.
Well this is one big time capsule time capsule time, capsule time,
capsule time caps, cap time, capsule time, capsule time, steel time,
kept steel time gap. You can sound good. Stop saying that now. Thank you.
I'm Jad Abumrad.
This is radio lab series about science and discovery and that exactly what we
have for you today.
Three detective stories and each one begins with a rather peculiar clue clues
that leads you back into the past time capsule time capsule and now that we've
got that phrase in our minds and garbage as well,
let's go to a different part of the world and get things started for real to
different time. Also 1898 Egypt, Oxford, Rinkus,
Egypt. You with me? Where's Oxa? Rinkus Egypt. It's in the south,
in the desert south of uh, of Cairo I think. And let me show you a picture.
You see the desert? Oh yeah. It's a big flat sort of sandy place.
And he's, who is this guy? Well, you should see two guys. They are,
they're two Oxford archeologists with a pit helmet and sort of standing high on
a mountain looking down. Yeah. One guy is on top of the mountain,
the other is toward the bottom that's Grenfell and hunt to Oxford archeologists.
They were in Egypt in 1898 looking for treasure.
And they find those sand dunes,
which don't look quite like the other sand dunes really.
They're sort of strange and irregularly shaped,
which is why when they saw those Sandana that you're looking at,
they hired a team of workers and they started to date the mission and the
immediately right
to find things. Huge quantity of pottery flows, shoes of baskets,
rope. That's Derek Obinc, a scholar from Oxford.
He tells the story of what they found and what they found was basically the
motherload,
a huge circle of rubbish mounds over 20 of them that were completely
undisturbed. Awe.
This was no piddly little trash sheep that was 50 years old like you might find
in Staten Island. These mounds, when you hear the,
these were rubbish mounts that had built up over the course of 10 centuries,
10 centuries of trash.
That's a a thousand years of trash. Yeah,
and that included a lot of ancient paper.
That's what they were really interested in.
Any scraps or squirrels they could find,
and one of the first ones that they pulled out of the ground was last sayings of
Jesus. Wow. Oh, that was the first one that they pulled out of the ground.
He who knows the all but fails to know himself,
lacks everything. If they say to you once, have you come, okay,
forget the 10 year old hot dog here we have come from the light.
We have sayings of Jesus cell phones,
which have not been seen read or even heard about for almost 2000 years.
A long list of sayings that are not in the canonical books of the Bible.
He who seeks let him not cease seeking until he finds this is a different Jesus
than the one in the Bible. It's almost to will not eastern in tone.
He says low heaven. There is here.
The Kingdom of the father is spread out upon the earth.
It's all around us and men do not see it. If we just opened our eyes.
[inaudible] today is known as the log ear fragment
and there was buried in the trash. Wow. Anyhow,
the team pulled as much paper as they could from the mounds,
separated out all the shoes and stuff and just took the paper
and then they packed those up into hundreds of boxes and ship them back to here
to Oxford.
This is the Sacrad library in Oxford and we're still today 107 years later.
We're going upstairs now. We're still today opening those boxes,
pulling out the fragments,
piecing them back together and decipher in them
[inaudible]
this is what 2000 year old paper sounds like.
sounds just like paper and it looks like dried leaves and not really much to
look at or listened to,
but knowing that it's 2000 years old in theoretically could have been written on
by Jesus himself on that makes it a little
more special,
which is why we visited Oxford England where the dump now lives packed away and
700 boxes.
The suboxone contains about 600 unpublished with clarity. Nick Ganas,
one of the collections curators popped one open for us
just opening.
I know official document sometime early fourth century
[inaudible].
Of course it's full of holes probably caused by little worms and there's the sad
part. There are enough secrets in these boxes to rewrite the past.
The problem is much of this is very hopelessly fragmented.
Reading it is almost impossible. Some of the smaller fragments,
if you see lots of them, they look like and conglomeration of cornflakes.
There will be a few hundred years before we even the most substantial of these
fragments come to light.
We're talking about the reconstruction of, of works that the work on,
which is beyond the scale of a single human lifetime. Way Beyond.
In the past 107 years,
the Oxford team has worked their way through a whopping 1% of the collection.
It may take another 10 centuries to get through the rest.
Here's how it usually goes. Nick scours the boxes each day, finds a new scrap,
tiny little scrap and brings it into the lab for cleaning.
What I do now is I renewed some ancient mud with the help of a brush
here. He wipes ancient mud from a torn page of Homer's Iliad.
After it's mud free. Each piece is catalog the computer for various
features like type of hand writing, size and style
piece seems to match the other pieces. Dirk and maybe a Grad student,
spread them all out on a long wooden table and basically from there it's a
classic jigsaw.
How about this one? Just met with click.
These might be the vine beginnings of move one here.
I think that that looks like it's promising that see if the words match up cause
they seem to line up pretty exactly with the lines of the verge of fragment.
May take five minutes, it may take five years.
We take five lifetimes, but eventually they will have,
well not the whole story, not even a page or the whole story.
Something
I've put the parties on to an electronic microscope.
Maybe just a few Greek words from the deep past Jose pawn pro,
yet a criterion tapey boost on the shoulder and contact about 10 part
[inaudible]. Don't loan it to get
[inaudible] a bet.
We missing a bet from the upper right corner.
Sometimes a sentence breaks off just when you need it to tell you what you need
to know.
We have to be satisfied with knowing of little rather than a lot amount.
Make sure I understand this as,
is each of these fragments just a teeny like is it a
to B or it's more like to, what was that smell?
Some of them are tiny, tiny.
I mean there was about a half a million in total and uh,
and they've only got through about 5,000 is do you have in your own list of
things like a, a sort of fever hits list? I do. I do.
I've narrowed it down to uh, to my top three,
my top three ancient garbage greatest hits, if you will, which was difficult.
But here are three that are really interesting. First number three,
ancient garbage, greatest hits. Number three, you being a death metal fan,
I'm sure are familiar with these three in auspicious number
[inaudible] absolutely.
Six six, six sign of the beast. Right.
Just to explain that the number of the beast, six 66 is what you use to others,
some of the beast or to keep the beast away because you can't say his name
directly. That would be bad. Yeah. All this comes from the New Testament. Okay.
Derek showed me a piece of a virus that he found in the dump.
It's about the size of your palm. So what are we looking at?
This looks like there's maybe 30 letters,
a copy of precisely that passage in the new testament where the number is
staying him. Who? Half on the stabbing.
Reckon the number of the beast for it is a human number.
It's number is 666, six,
six six which was the traditional number.
The bees. Here's the thing,
this little scrap of Papaya is the Dirk turned up is the earliest known copy
that we have of that passage. He showed me. Can you,
can you point to the letters again and, and,
and show me what his three numbers are. Smack in the center of the piracy,
clutters kind, Yoda Sigma Chi, Yoda,
Sigma Chi Yoda Sigma should say six six, six, right? Yep.
But in fact, Chi, Yoda, sigma, don't say six six, six they don't,
what do they say? Six six one one six.
No, sort of six six, six really? Yeah.
Does that mean all the bibles are wrong or maybe, I mean,
all we really know is that the number of the beast had versions and at six one
six, maybe the original,
how long does it take this to filter into the King James Bible or something
like,
oh no.
It will appear in the next standard edition of the New Testament in a note on
that page representing it as a viable variant that is now appeared in a puppy.
Totally. What does the biblical scholars excepted? Did they do? Oh,
so it, you should just probably be very careful about six blank six from them.
If you want worrying about the beast,
well you should probably change your tattoo
shit. All right, let's move on to number two garbage.
Greatest hits number two. Did you see the movie Troy? Yes.
You remember the scene?
Good job.
Big Bold, muscular men fighting big bold,
muscular fights with big bowls and muscular enemies.
John [inaudible]
the film and I know how big bold and muscular blocks.
What did your scrap tell you? Well, they've been very flux recently.
This is big news in the, in the world of the pup biologists,
they got their hands on this special camera.
So we have this digital set up here, a camera on a uh,
on an assertive easel.
This camera uses infrared filters to photograph text.
It's so faded that you can't really see it with the naked eye. Take a
quite a long exposure. In any case,
the first thing that they read with that camera is a poem about the Trojan War,
new poem of our killer Co's. This poem, our gay own F,
our base pollution strut on Hoyt or peppontone comes from the six hundreds,
not homer. It's our silicosis version.
It's precisely not homer because whereas the Homeric version,
the Brad Pitt version, it goes, uh, you know, Grayson VAYD, Troy falls, harass
this version goes Greeks invade, get their butts kicked,
and then run, run like sissies.
Oh, so it completely turns the Homeric account on its head. Wait, wait, wait.
This was great.
At the same time as homework a little bit later, but in response to that,
oh, and the Greek goes like this. Here, listen.
Hey to tell you craft one doesn't have to call it weakness and cowardess having
to retreat note at trip. No, it does exist at proper time for flight.
See, Homer's notion was that like the hero stands and fights to the end, but,
but this poet was saying, you know what? No, we ran away.
We turned our backs to flee quickly and that's okay.
He actually celebrated it as something that he was proud of because sometimes
you had to turn and run.
[inaudible]
running away is a good thing. Running away is a good thing. That's good one.
See what's interesting about the past you find in the trash is that it's messy.
It's complicated. There's not just a story.
You know there's contradictions to that story. Competing accounts of that story,
which can be disconcerting. I mean,
you know who wants to have different bibles floating around.
That can be weird for people, but to me to know that way back when,
even then there were different ideas about what it means to be a hero.
[inaudible]
that I find comforting,
which brings us to my first choice. I last but hardly least ancient garbage.
Greatest hit none. Well, the greatest hit.
What do you think people in the first century were reading?
What do I think they were reading?
[inaudible] what do you think they were really reading?
Okay. When the, when the tech starts, she's saying, Oh, I'm terribly on fire,
and that goes in Greek. Do know, flag of my realm.
A May a k, d, I'll say the translation.
Oh, it's thick and big as a roof B,
and then she goes on [inaudible]
hard. That's what they were reading.
This filthy satire turned up enough times in this and other dumps for Dirk to
suspect that it may have been a bestseller.
So there was more than one version of yes, it appeared over and over and over.
I'm burning. I'm on fire. I'm terribly on fire.
A stream runs over me. Do you understand?
And I'm being a bit [inaudible].
You're listening to radio lab
from New York public radio.
V. U. N. N. N. P. R. Wait, what? What?
[inaudible]
keep listening. Okay.
[inaudible].
This podcast of radio lab is supported by the innovators and organic tastes
creators at honesty,
certified organic bottled tea since 1999 honesty is brewed with real organic tea
leaves and ingredients staying true to nature.
Honesty's just a tad sweet drinks can be found wherever beverages are sold.
More information about honesty's mission in a bottle is available at
facebook.com/honesty nature. Got It right. We put it in a bottle. Honest,
this is Radiolab. I'm Jad Abumrad and I'm Robert Krulwich. I,
our show today is about finding clues to the past and the weirdest places and
there is no weirder place to find the past than in the story you're about to
hear.
It comes to us from Laura Star Chesky who herself likes to get in the whole
thing. Yeah.
This my mom,
my mom kind of fostered that like when we were a little one of our hip outings
so that we would do,
would be to go to this toxic dump near my house where I grew up.
It's like on top of a mountain.
They sealed off this mountain and they made all the people move off of it.
So you're just walking along a trail and then you see all these old abandoned
houses full of stuff. So we would go into the houses and we find pay stubs,
we find dishes, we'd find paintings and we try and figure out why.
Like even though we knew really why the people had left,
we would try and make up other stories about why they left. Like,
maybe they were fighting in the middle of dinner and they just had all of their
dishes on the table.
All right. Fast forward many years.
Laura is in New York and one day she gets a call from her sister who tells her,
I just heard the most amazing story.
I was at my writing class and the teacher told us this story.
You should call him Eric Gordon is his name.
Take your tape recorder over to his office in Manhattan.
Make him tell it to you. So that's what she did.
I just said at first, you know, I just want to record you telling this story.
Hey Dude,
how he had found all these letters and photos and created a character
[inaudible]
I had no idea that I would become so,
okay. So do you want to talk about that day?
Get the story took place? Sure. That day,
let me see if I can put my self back in that day. Uh,
so I was living in Oakland at the time.
This is about 1994 and decided to go on a weekend camping trip with a friend and
we're driving south on route one oh one through the central part of the state.
And my friend starts to frantically shout, look, look.
And she's pointing out to this field, she can't even get the words out.
She's saying, look looking. She shouting. So he tries to look.
I turned my head very quickly and you can't see because its view is blocked by
an overpass or a hill and he just has no idea what she's talking about.
And she is stuttering her words and she says there's,
and she's still stuttering. [inaudible] standing there,
the cows back in that field. Oh,
what a goat standing on top of a cow goat standing on top of a cow.
Yeah. And you know, of course my reaction is, is this,
that's absurd. And she's saying, pull this truck over, pull over.
And she's getting really angry. And I said,
I'm not backing up three quarters of a mile and one oh one she said,
they argue for a little while. And Eric finally relent.
20 minutes later they arrived back at the field.
So we pull over and she just gets the hugest grin on her face.
There is in fact a goat standing on a cow's back still there.
We sit in the truck for a minute watching this cow who's close enough to the
fence that we got a very good view of it and every time he takes a step to graze
the goats kind of shifts from side to side balancing.
So they're kind of this unit, I mean really amazing.
You actually could see that goats hooks kind of bunch up in the cow's skin and
we get out of the truck slowly get out of the truck to get a better left and
right as I shut the door, I go jumps off and go jumps off
and you just, you know,
we're standing there kind of dumped on and we move up to the,
to the fence and just believe it or not, the story gets weirder really?
Yeah.
So Eric and his friend are standing totally still hoping that if they just wait,
maybe the Godel jump back onto the cow and all of a sudden Eric's friend notices
something at her feet. She bends down and picks up a letter,
a letter right in front of the fence and it's an old man.
It's kind of like 50 years old, Chris Brown.
Then we looked at the post-market us in 1952 an open this thing up and read it
and it's almost about nothing. My dear.
I wrote you up card after receiving the first one. Yeah. See,
some of these are so tough to read,
so I looked down on the ground and there's another letter.
I've been slowly getting on my feet again and another and it is so much better.
It looks like that's her loop to that f another.
Albertine sings very well indeed since you ask.
She told politically they were blown literally in this line down the side of the
highway and we looked at each other and frantically started gathering these
letters, filling our arms with them.
Letters from the 1920s I see at 1937 postmark and then she shouts from a couple
feet away. 1897 1890 I'm gathering, my arms are getting full.
I run to the truck and grab a garbage bag and I start filling it up and then I
start to notice Ella chase, Ella chase, Ella chase, Ella chase.
These letters are all written to the same woman.
[inaudible]
over 300 letters, all written to one woman,
Ella Chase, you know, forget the goat and the cow.
Now we're standing in the middle of the somebody's whole life correspondence
spread out on the side of Highway One oh one and we just read and we read and we
read into the night.
Let me see if I can find this. A really,
soaps that day back in 1994 began a 12 year obsession with Ella chase.
These letters are maybe Eric's favorite thing in the whole world.
He keeps them in this big archival box in his closet.
Now what's really interesting is there are a ton of letters that are written to
her as mother or mom.
And first thing Eric pulls out is this big stack of letters written to Ella
during World War II.
Probably have 40 letters from boys in the navy to La Chase with that red by
sensors stamp on the letter where they're calling her mom.
I'll read you one and this is one that I act
April 2nd, 1941 from a GI named w Murphy and he writes,
well mom,
I hope you don't mind me calling it this cause you were swelled to me and just a
mother to me and I hope I can be seeing you again and keep writing to me if you
will. I sure enjoyed hearing from you.
Hope you received the letter that I wrote a few days ago,
but mail is a little slow going and coming out here. I'm feeling fine.
Only a little tired,
but that's nothing unusual as we are pretty busy all the time.
Oh my better clothes and say a prayer for me if you will. And God bless you.
Love W
Murphy, August 3rd, 1945 somewhere.
Do your mom with these kids? No, they're not our kids, they're boys.
1820 years old who were so attached to her just by writing to her that they
started to call her mom and there were like 40 of these letters and a number of
them, from what I can tell in the letters, I have never actually met her.
So she became this matriarch to all of these men in the war.
I had never seen anything like that before. Yeah. There's so much.
Something like this. I mean I was just amazed by the reach of her personality.
You know, he showed me dozens of letters thanking her. You look at this,
I am so very grateful. Thank you for what you did for my husband.
He is, thank you for changing the way that I think about my life. Whoa.
And these tend to be from people who I'd only met her once. Really? Yeah.
The reverence that people just speak to her. Um,
and you know, I can't figure out when she was married,
I can't figure out where she was married. She ran for political office.
I mean this is a fascinating woman. She ran for political office in the 1940s
but I don't know what office
and that's where the story ends. That's where the story ends. Yeah.
You mean Eric has never tried to find out anything more?
Remember how I told you he was a teacher before? Yeah.
He started bringing all these letters into his classroom and ended up designing
this whole curriculum around them. I collaborated with the history teacher.
The kids would each get a photograph, you have to put it in a plastic sleeve.
Each one of the kids, whenever they handled them,
had to put on surgical gloves in history.
The students with research that time period,
and then ultimately they'd bring that work back to my classroom,
my English classroom, and they would start writing historical fiction.
Eric would ask each student to create that ghost biography of LFA swollen s
history, using her letters as a springboard. And some of the, you know,
some of the pieces were wonderful. He just incredible.
He even had them title their papers. My ELA.
That's what's been much more meaningful to me.
So the way Eric sees it,
the real Ella was abandoned and he's given her new life.
You know, I feel like a guardian of,
of this person's moment on the earth.
Okay. By that you can generally [inaudible] announcement for one 69
so here's the thing,
I was already going to California to visit a friend and I couldn't leave things
the way they were like the whole time when I would look at these letters and
look at the pictures, I would feel like there's more here.
And find time to San Jose will be approximately five hours and 56 minutes.
How did someone who reached out to all of these people end up with their life on
the side of the highway in [inaudible]?
I really wanted to know, do you want to see some of this stuff?
Cause I brought it and brought some, I knew I needed help.
So I contacted this friend of a friend, Marina Cole.
She's this amateur expert in genealogical research and I showed her the letters.
Wait, you had the letters to Derrick give them to? Yeah.
Even though he was convinced that they were abandoned. He told me, you know,
I would love to find family that this would truly mean something to do.
Your mom? Yes. It's not her son. It's,
I'm one of these letters from the World War Two soldiers who all called her mom.
Oh Wow. Soon as I started showing marina the letters,
her face kind of lit up. Oh shoot. It's amazing.
The first thing we decided to do is to go to a historical society. Um,
this woman, we know that she lived in Lomita Park.
Since this is for Daly City,
I assume that I went back and looked at census records to find out a little bit
more about her.
We found out that Ella had two granddaughters who are still alive.
So we sent letters to our granddaughters,
but
they'd never respond day to stay street to go Napa Valley highway.
My idea, my fantasy this whole time has been, we'll go to her house,
the address that's on the letters. I know. Maybe bring one of the letters.
It was a single story house. Little Rose Garden.
I think houses have a strong history. Yeah. Someone there.
We'll be able to tell us something about her. Are they coming or anything?
No answer. So we tried a neighbor.
What is it you want? Hi, I'm sorry. Rather you.
I'm looking to find information about a woman. [inaudible] idea.
We're new here on them. Okay. Well thank you so much.
Yeah,
the missing husband. I can't find anything on him at all.
He's a complete mystery. I mean there were a lot of unanswered questions,
so we knew that we had to find Ellis obituary.
Day three, the Napa Public Library
right
in front of the microphone. We're scrolling through dates.
August 22nd this was kind of our last hope.
Fuck Huh?
The death notice comes up on this screen. Chase in Napa Monday,
July 4th,
1915 we scan it as fast as we can just for any new names that we haven't seen
before. Rexford see green, no brain. Almost right away we notice Robert,
Robert Lilee. That's a great saying. There was a cancer, her grandson. Yeah.
We had never seen this name before.
He was listed. Bob Carol were either down at the store,
uh, give me some milk or we don't know where I am or worse. I'm a lawyer.
Hi, I'm, this is a message for Robert Lilee.
My name is Laura Star Chesky.
I'm a reporter and I'm doing a story about a woman, um,
who I believe is your grandmother.
I wanted to hear a voice. I wanted a voice.
Marina returned to Los Altos to get back to her life. And um,
I waited one day past and another,
I didn't get a call back from him.
Day Six.
It was marine
marina. Ah,
she hadn't been able to start researching. Okay.
It's really sad. What is it? Well, in 1938,
she filed for divorce
and there was a series of articles
where he denies that they were married.
Really?
She pleaded with me to marry her. Ella did,
but we couldn't get along and I refused to do it. He
was desperate for money. He to sell the house.
She couldn't do that without divorcing her husband.
Trial of sensational. I'm not married. Case expected in June.
It went on for like a year. The huge headlines Ellis had.
They were married Bellman. Her husband says that they never were.
Ella couldn't produce a marriage certificate and then finally the whole thing
ended with her just sitting in the courtroom refusing to answer questions.
Chase of Lomita park still adamant and defiant,
but this time alone steadfastly refused to answer questions
that really wasn't the worst of it.
There's this really sad article from a few years later, you can find this
[inaudible]
Christmas,
1942 death took no holiday on Christmas eve bellman,
chase wandered along, dimmed out south of market.
He had been drinking heavily. He was separated from his wife and family.
Perhaps he was trying to erase thoughts that come to men at such time.
Christmas Day sprawled on his back on a sidewalk.
He died for warm sun,
shone clear on the fractured nose and the Blue Bruise on his chin.
Looks like the bomb is dead. Someone said
a couple of days later, it says that his body was left unclaimed in the morgue.
Really they were not able to locate his. A strange Dwight
really, it suddenly made sense.
It was right after that that she started writing to World War II soldiers.
She probably needed them as much as they needed her day.
Seven Holy Cross cemetery in South San Francisco.
Oh, look, look.
Wow.
It's a nice headstone. It's a really nice, had snow.
It was gray and unpolished and she was buried with her mother and father.
I wish I had brought flowers.
I know I could go pick some flowers right over there.
Okay. Yeah, let's do that. Okay.
[inaudible] they're at right a hop position. As soon as I got back,
I went to Eric's office.
I had all these newspaper clippings in my bag and I was ready to show him.
How were you feeling at this point? I was feeling a little nervous. Yeah.
Some of it is kind of sad and I just want to make sure that you're ready for
that.
It's not necessarily positive enlightenment about her family,
so let me get it up.
As I'm taking the stuff
out of my backpack,
she stops me right before I hand it to him.
There's a part of me that's not sure that I want to see it.
[inaudible].
Yeah.
I think if there's no one that would receive these artifacts ultimately or that
we have some sort of connection and appreciation to them,
I'm not sure I want to say it.
You don't want to know any of it. I don't
if there's, don't want to take them over. Um,
I want to live with them as a mystery.
I couldn't blame Eric.
I was even a little bit jealous of him at that point because he got to choose
whether or not to look at this stuff. So with that, hey
went home.
But as soon as I got home there was a message on my answering machine.
Hi, this message is from Laura. My name is Bob [inaudible],
grandson of the Ella Chase and he called him up to message for me,
try and get ahold of you regarding some of the pictures and letters and stuff
that was found along the road site.
I take action to help fill in the pieces for the puzzle cause they probably came
out of my truck on the way from San Jose to southern California.
I have some pretty big news for you. Okay. As soon as I got home.
After I talked to you on Friday, I got a message from Ellis grandson.
He's the one who dropped the box
during the course of driving down highway one oh one taking these boxes home in
the back of my pickup that several of them blew out. Okay.
He tried to pull over and get it right.
Stopped alongside the road and my wife was with me and we picked up everything
we could.
Yeah. But as soon as he started to collect it,
the California highway patrol pulled over and told them that he had to keep
going.
They were going to give me a ticket for littering
because the stuff's scattered everywhere.
This stuff was just blowing everywhere
and he has a whole bunch of boxes like the one that fell off.
I'm still going through this stuff and it's been 1213 years.
I love that you actually found who dropped this stuff and did you sound sad
about it? What was his reaction? He just seemed the happy go lucky about it.
He was like, I think I can solve your mystery. Cause I,
when I was talking to Bob, I told him about Eric of course.
And I told him how much Eric cared about all this stuff and he was really
relieved. He didn't think it was weird at all.
He just was glad that someone had cherished this stuff and he came up with the
idea right away of sending Eric kind of a replacement.
I have another group
of pictures, this Bob, all of Ellis stuff.
Bob Sent Eric this mystery box full of photos that he couldn't explain.
I still can't get over the timing though. Like, okay,
so Bob passes by in the truck, the box flies out and then what?
Like a couple of hours later,
this goat jumps on a cow's back and causes these two people to stop and get the
letters basically. Do you think the goat on a cow was a sign?
What do you mean Zeus saying, stop Derek. Stop.
I think you could tell it that way, but goats like to stand on top of cows.
Really? Yeah. Goats like to stand on top of anything high.
If there's a fence to the jump on top of it. There's a house,
they'll try and climb it. That's what goats do you think so?
How do you know all this? I've seen goats. You know,
my mom used to send me up the road to buy eggs from this woman who had all these
goats and they had a little goat shack and all the goats would be clustered on
top of the goat shack.
Although they had a whole yard full of scraggly grass and grazing.
Did you ever say to Eric, Eric goats just kinda like to do this?
No, I never said that to him. I mean, okay, good.
It's like the stand on tall things, but since when does a cow not care?
The goat's not extraordinary. It's the cow. It's a nonchalant cow.
Yes. Hmm.
[inaudible]
Laura Starecheski is a producer. She lives in New York and non chalant cow.
Well, I hope you'll stay with us.
Our next detective story begins with a drop of blood and from the blood we
discover 16 and a half million baby boys. This is Radiolab.
I'm Jad Abumrad Robert Krulwich, which, and I will continue in a moment.
You're listening to radio lab from New York public radio, public radio.
[inaudible], e. N. N. P. R.
This is Radiolab. I'm Jad up. I'm Rod and I'm Robert Krulwich.
Today on our program,
stories about stumbling onto the past and finding surprises.
Strange things which brings us to DNA.
DNA is used to track crimes. This we know from police dramas like CSI,
far less glamorously but no less. Interestingly,
historians and geneticists use DNA to go way back in time and answer basic
questions about who we are and where we came from.
And that is an unlikely development if you think [inaudible].
Yeah, cause usually when you know, if someone has sex with someone else,
the DNA gets mixed.
So the DNA is always changing from one generation to the next.
It's always getting jumbled up.
One would think it would be hard to keep track of across time. Yeah, but
and here's what you need to know. For our next segment,
there are patches of DNA which don't change.
The y chromosome is the one of these places.
This is the chromosome that men have that women don't have.
And when a father has a son,
he gives his son an exact copy of his y chromosome,
sort of like xerox.
Then when many years later, the boy has a boy of his own
[inaudible].
Nothing happens in exact copy of the why
on and on and on down the male line. Now
here's where it gets interesting.
Every so often the cellular xerox makes a mistake,
a tiny mistake, sort of like at work.
When you put the paper on the copier in the copy, it's spits back out at you,
has a little smudge on it, little Spec, maybe some dust got in there. Who knows?
It's not a big deal. I mean you can still read that text,
but this new Munchie copy is in its way
Munich. It's no longer just to copy cause it's got that Spec on it.
[inaudible] this is where the analogy breaks down a bit.
Granted because a paper with the SPEC is not a very interesting thing,
but a y chromosome with a mutation is useful cause geneticists can look at that
little Spec, that little mutation on the y and say that right there.
That came from one man somewhere in time.
It's a clue and since they know that little mutation will get copied and yeah,
you got me,
they know that everyone else who shows up with it is descended from that man.
Now,
this principle that a particularly mutation on the y chromosome comes from an
individual back in time brings us to a wonderful story that I want to tell you.
Once upon a time a group of scientists led by this guy. Yeah,
I am a Spencer wells. I'm a population geneticists.
Got into a Land Rover and headed off to Asia on what they call a blood sampling
tool.
He set off in April of 1998 on a six month odyssey and it was literally four
guys
and that it wasn't just four guys, so my name is [inaudible].
I'm an Italian researcher. Yeah. She flew over for about three weeks.
I joined them in Ashkelon. She came with us to Kyrgyzstan,
taking samples on the caucuses to the Altai mountains,
driving all over centrally. Each said 10 hours.
Hinton come from place to place weeping like 10 we sampled.
It was a thousand people. It was really an adventure.
So here's what they do. Each village they'd come to,
they'd find out who was in charge and then they'd sit down with him or her.
Describe the project. Simple terms,
basically make sure that we had permission to do the airplane.
They'd say to the chief, okay, we are here. Tell good story.
The history of your people, your family.
Because by looking closely at the DNA in an ordinary blood sample,
we can discover where your ancestors came from, where they went,
who they conquered, who conquered them.
Or we can go back hundreds of generations and typically most people would
willingly give us blood sample.
Awesome.
Well, what were they looking for exactly? Or I guess what were they,
what do they expect to find? Well,
this same group had done this in Europe and when they did it in Europe,
when they took blood from people, they found lots and lots of very distinct,
separate families with very separate ancestors. That makes sense.
That's what they were expecting to find in Asia, but that's not what they found.
Wow.
Any case, Spencer,
it gives Tatyana a batch of the DNA samples almost 2017 it goes back to her lab
in London. And the goal again was, was very kind of open ended.
What are the genetic patterns in Central Asia
that China gets all her DNA,
lays it out and begins to investigate and right away something's a little odd.
[inaudible]
uh,
I really thought we've made a mistake in sample after sample after sample.
She could see a specific mutation and we knew that everybody that presented that
mutation come from one individual, sometimes in the past,
meaning all those modern Asian guys from Uzbekistan and Kazakhstan and Mongolia
and China,
people who came from very different ancient tribes and should have only the most
distant family connections. Weirdly,
they shared a fairly recent Greek Greek, Greek, Greek, Greek, great,
great grandparents. No one ever seen anything like this before. No.
She asked for her boss to come. Yeah, I'm Chris Titus Smith.
And she showed him the data. As soon as we saw that,
we knew that that couldn't happen by chance so low.
So the first thing she wanted to know was when did this mysterious person,
when did he live? So using some statistical programs,
she plugged the data into a computer program and asked it to count backwards to
the first moment when the mutation appeared in the program.
Saving roughly 1000 years, a thousand years ago, give or take 200 years.
This person live now. Now this is interesting.
If you are alive a thousand years ago and you had a son and that son had a son,
so forth, you would have right now about 800 living descendants.
This person,
whoever he was has right now like 16 millions of 16 million descendants.
Yeah, it's a lot. Yeah. Yes, absolutely.
[inaudible]
now here's where it gets interesting, Tatyana. I got herself a map. Yeah.
I had the map of the region and I spread on a map.
The frequency of these linens.
She began putting pins where ever she saw heavy concentrations of the mutation
in Mongolia, put a pin in Mongolian China, China's Iberia, Siberia.
Pakistan has exten Pakistan and then she stood back and looked at this map.
These pins spread all across Asia and she's like, now wait a second.
So then you had realized that the spread of this lineage was perfectly matching
the spread of the Mongol Empire. As soon as she saw it,
they went to Greece and Tatiana said to him, you know Chris,
I think I found kings county.
Ooh,
that's pretty interesting.
I knew just what I studied when I was at high school,
if I didn't really know much about it, but she knew the basics.
In the 13th century Gangas Kahn United the tribes of Mongolia into a massive
army and they rode west,
literally killing thousands and thousands of men.
So that means removing competitors if you kill them and you
[inaudible]. And then with all those men and their y chromosomes out of the way,
Gingiss slept with a whole lot of ladies.
It's true. He, I believe he slept with many, many women. That's what she read.
Wild, fantastic tales.
Myths really have harems that numbered in the hundreds.
I mean the stories when they were getting into new village,
he was the one picking up the youngest women and keeping them for himself.
Shingles undoubtedly had a number of quite a number of sexual partners.
We want to just be a little careful here, so we called up an expert. Yeah.
Ms Maurice for Sabi,
a professor of Mongolian history from Columbia University and arranged for
breakfast. Can I get a couple of scrambled eggs? Yes. I have read accounts. I,
I don't know how a wheelie are, where the mangoes would come conquer
territory and there was a save the pretty ones for the boss kind of rule.
Is that true at all? Yes, that's true.
One story is that he was murdered by one of these women who had sex with that
she placed a knife in her vagina and as they were having sex,
he was stabbed and killed. Whether that's true or not,
that's an interesting story.
Well, whatever.
If gangas did have the power to command any woman he wanted and if the dates
were right for history and the places were right geographically,
all the evidence points in the same direction,
that looks like a duck and it walks like a duck. Yeah.
The inference was that it was a dock.
This was this Kangaskhan is y chromosome lineage.
And so 23 scientists from all over the world together announced in the American
Journal of human genetics.
That gang is Khan was very probably the most successful biological father in
human history. Human history. Yes. Which in all of time, in all of time.
And the thing about this story is it really,
really it caught people's attention because this is one of those things where
you can actually do something about it. You can take those DNA tests. Sorry,
I just lost my earphones. I got so excited. Yes, I know. The DNA test,
the swab, your growth cheeks. Put it in a vile.
Send them back to these companies.
I may send you big tell you whether you have Gingiss con's marker.
How much are these tests? How much about not? I don't know.
I know it depends on 300 bucks. 300 hundred bucks. Your check for 300 bucks.
I can find out if I'm related to gangs cause yeah, I bet I am.
I bet you Nah,
cause his conquest routes ended sort of near Lebanon where my folks are from.
[inaudible] come on.
Look at suckers like you who were perfect marks for businesses
like this. We found this restaurant in London
called shish called call what? Shish. Shish because for short,
for Shish Kebab,
they announced a major Gingiss con promotion 10 when is had DNA testing done and
Oxford find out if they were ancestors of Kangaskhan.
This was a very unique and the response was just people came carrying demand.
There were lines around the block phone call. The phones were ringing all day.
I mean I never thought that would have been that interest cause after,
I'll put this in your own mind, if you're sitting there thinking, well,
if I'm related to Gangas Kahn, that explains my extraordinary backhand.
See you weren't the only one.
There were a lot of people working under strange illusions like you a lot.
Let me ask you this though. If I,
let's say I had taken a test and came up positive,
I am so it seems related to gangs, Khan,
does that really mean anything definitively? I mean, is that marker for sure.
Gangs, cons, marker. Do we know that? In fact, no.
The only way you ever know for sure that it's anybody's mutation is you've got
to go to the body, pluck some DNA from the body, see if it matches the mutation.
So you got to find Gingiss cons body. Yeah, that would be the ultimate proof.
[inaudible]
and by the way, there's a lot of people looking, oh my God. Oh,
found a human skull buried in the England barrier.
I have been doing this now for going on to eating the half years and we've dug
up with some very nice fellas so far. That guy is Maury cravats.
This voice you hear is a direct result of screaming for years.
He was a commodities trader in Chicago. Yeah,
I was a warrior of the trading pits. He got just enough money actually.
He made quite a bit of money to sponsor annual summer trips looking for Gangas
cons corpse. Why is he looking for gangs? Con Valuables? Great.
Well cause he knows that for all the sacking and pillaging that the Mongols did
back in the 12 hundreds chis this day. Not One virtual dagger,
not one necklace, not one diamond studded Tiara,
which could be identified from the 13 gentry has ever sugarfish suggesting that
might be all under the surface of the ground.
Similar to suggesting that it all went south with the old man.
So there might be two treasures here.
Here's the physical treasure and the biological treasure.
Well that's where a scientist,
I am a different sort of Genghis Khan man,
but you're not going to be able to do a proper DNA search unless the guy like me
find the tomb boy says if there is a treasure,
he will happily hand it over to the Mongolian government officials are a little
leery excavation. So he continues to plead his case.
Okay. If we FG you must, sorry. Exactly. Must be [inaudible]
what do you mean no?
And he keeps digging up bodies always with the same result. Well,
it's not [inaudible] not
[inaudible] [inaudible]
the problem is nobody knows where Gangas Kahn is buried.
They don't even know if he was buried.
They don't even know if there's any place there thing to find.
Uh, it appears unlikely.
Professor Mushavi says no looking for Gangas is uh, I don't know.
He died in 1227 and they had no tradition of tumor culture at that point.
The body was just left word.
So does that mean we'll never know? No,
there may be a way out of this.
Gingiss con he had a grandson who bla con
the famous emperor of China.
Cuba has the same exact mutation that his grandpa had.
That's the nature of [inaudible].
And I think more likely discovery will be of cougar cons. Joe,
why not look for coop? We're use [inaudible].
Would you get, well,
we know as stated in the sources as somewhere in Mongolia when it is discovered,
it'll be a real bonanza. Yeah. So you talked to Marie,
everybody, it seems to me you can go on the funds that you idiot.
You're looking for the wrong guy. Well wait,
I'm going to cut you off. Morris or Sabby is going to say,
I'm looking for the wrong guy. You know it's true.
He happens to Kubelet con as the, his, his, his pitch and speakers.
He wrote a book on Coupla Con. Okay. Okay.
The point is both gangas and Kubelet con have the same genetic markets.
If you find either one, either one,
we'll do pluck a hair from either guy's body, look up the DNA,
and then you will know for sure if gangas and his family not only conquered the
ancient world, but fathered the modern world one day we will know
[inaudible].
And I guess the neat thing about all of these tales is you know,
you think when you're going to tell a story from the past at the sensible place
to go is you go to the library, you go to a fossil, you go to were ruined.
The truth is you can go anywhere.
The blood coursing through your veins tells you, I have a story for you.
Same with a little bit of garbage that sits next to an ancient shoe.
You pluck the piece of paper and Jesus is talking to you. Literally,
there are clues about the past everywhere,
and if it's a knock on your door and you decide to open the door and take a
look, who knows what you will find it. Who knows where you will go. By the way,
the video clip used in that last segment was provided courtesy of AMD networks.
And for more information on anything you heard this hour, visit our website,
radio lab.org can communicate it with us while you're there. It's,
here's our address radio lab@wnyc.org is our email address.
I'm Jad Abumrad, Robert Croach and I are signing off. Thanks for listening.